there's a problem with our spreadsheet
okay well it's not a problem it's a
limitation I'll show you why right as we
went through this right what we had to
do was we had to say okay look if we
earn this amount then we started a
formula right and then we worked out all
of our cells on the assumption that
we're in this tax bracket the one that
has this rule to it freedom but if we
earn more or if we think about well what
happens if we go from more years right
suppose I say let's go into here instead
of weeks worth leak was 48 right if i
want to say well what happens after five
years right or what happens if yeah okay
let's just multiply by 5 okay now you
could work out you could say five times
forty eight equals etc but come on are
you getting a theme yet it's a
spreadsheet you don't do it for you so
all you have to do is say it goes five
times they go and it'll work out the
number for you okay now again the
numbers are too big so just double big
and there you go but here's a problem
right we've worked out this gross income
but now we're not in the same tax
bracket right we're not in this rule
doesn't apply anymore if you come back
to our table where are we sorry the
number 115 okay so where are we where
yeah here we are ok so this rule doesn't
apply anymore and neural appliance okay
so how we go we don't want to have to
manually change every time we want the
spreadsheet to do that for us ok so I'm
going to teach you a bit of offense and
triticale ensued I want you to go here
start a brand new sheet because we're
going to do a bit of experimenting yeah
yeah sure ok so I had 48 here before
didn't I yeah ok so i wanted to multiply
that by five so you know a monkey's way
of doing it the same 5 x 48 working out
and then putting that number in but i'm
going to get the spreadsheet to do it so
i'll say equals 5 x 48
whatever that might be and you hit it up
so then your formulas might not be there
see my normal formulas right see this
number it's not really a number it's a
formula that gives me a number and
that's the whole point of the
spreadsheet okay are your formulas oh
yeah that'll be is ok it only it only
takes one link in the chain right
because then everything else will
reflect that okay so let's start a new
sheet so come down here if you can't
remember it's this little arm this
little square rectangle with a star on
it in solar check yup okay start fresh
start fresh fresh sheet okay so let's do
some stuff on this let me make an even
bigger please okay here we go so what I
want us to imagine is okay um we've got
a brand new spreadsheet and this time
it's a arm it's a fitness adviser okay
it's a fitness adviser it's a very
simple one okay it's a very simple one
so all it tells you is if you tell it a
weight right how much you weigh okay and
you can make up this number then it'll
give you some advice okay so i made a I
you talk about how to make a new sheet
sure but how did you okay so up in there
up in the top here on this bit where I
can control the columns right if you put
your mouse in between a collar in
between two columns then you can adjust
you can trade it so this is really
simple right now um let's just suppose
okay a person weighs 65 kilograms okay
yeah I've um you know I let go a little
bit right side I put in some way so
we'll make a really simple um advice
give up right and the way it's going to
say is if you're above a certain way
it'll say go exercise and if you're
below a certain way it'll say you're
fine that's all it's going to do okay
you can make it fancy later if you look
so you start with an equation everything
start some incredible okay and what we
wanted to do is we want it to give
something different if this value is
above or below whatever okay so you
start by typing if okay so this is a
condition okay it's going to check this
thing over here see if it needs a
certain condition or not and then spit
out some advice okay so I open up a
bracket right and then you can see it
even tells you it gives you some advice
as to on what you need to put in here
okay so first it says we need a logical
text I'm going to write this down so you
can all follow me because if you miss a
bit it'll be tricky to catch up okay
yeah so logical test is like this right
so I'll say if now I want it to look at
this cell okay like so and we're gonna
say all all right let's just suppose if
you're over a hundred kilograms right
100 kilograms if it's greater than 100
yeah well I clicked on there but typing
a 2 will have the same effect so you can
see I've got an inequality symbol there
does that freak up that's greater than I
didn't think it has to be capitals but I
put them kept us just so I can see the
little more clearly okay if a 2 is
greater than 100 okay so that that
greater than sign right a 2 greater than
100 that's above the full stop okay so
shift will stop there going okay now put
a comma now we want to say well over
100k that is we want this advice giver
to say go on exercise ok so we're
literally going to write with quote
marks go and exercise they go okay so if
this number is over 100 that's what it's
going to say okay it's literally going
to write that and that's one's going to
reply ok so that's the value that this
cell will take if this condition is true
and that's why it says Val
yeah boss yeah it's backwards from my
your clothes got value of true / false
okay I haven't closed the bracket yet I
just put a comma so I've got you can you
get out it look exactly as mine looks ok
so if h is greater than hundred go and
exercise right so there's my advice so
what do you want to say if you're under
100 see ya okay I'm gonna do not ever
have another meal okay have a happy meal
fine okay with the point I've been a bit
of its personnel you are they going into
it so this is what it's going to say if
it's false and now I close my bracket ok
so that's everything okay three pieces
to it there's exercise or happy meal
yeah okay and then close the bracket
have you got everything there can you
see it all there okay is anyone's
working yeah yes someone's working on so
ends up is not working oh yeah okay as I
paid is good okay alright so now now you
can change your cell like over here
suppose I really really let go right and
then way 101 cute okay you can picture
me as a 180 okay survive press enter
surprise surprise it tells me to go an
exercise okay does that make sense so
it's changing like this is based on what
this says
makes it it just keeps on till you have
you lucky you ok is everyone a case of
fun so make sense yeah we're gonna use
this well if you're 101 killers I think
probably you should maybe ease off on
that take it I double clicked on it so
if you ever want to edit a cell and it's
got a formula in it if you double click
on it oh wow okay that makes sense and
obviously you can muck around with this
right you can say you know um you can
say you could say yeah you can be really
really harsh and safe losing it some way
please okay and it will reply whatever
you like okay